if you couldn't wait until Thursday
December 4th to play the uncharted 4
multiplayer beta then you're in luck the
Uncharted 4 a thieves n multiplayer beta
is coming sooner than expected Sony
announced today that the beta will begin
tomorrow December 3rd the news comes
from PlayStation Europe's official
Twitter account which also specifies
that the beta will be available starting
9 a.m. Pacific Standard Time the beta is
scheduled to end on December 13th though
it's still unclear if that's still the
case given that the beta start date has
been brought forward the Uncharted 4
multiplayer beta client is around 7
gigabytes to access the beta you will
have to have purchased uncharted 2
Nathan Drake collection as of yet Sony
has not announced any other way to get
in
according to dual shockers the Uncharted
4 multiplayer beta comes with two maps
and one mode the beta represents just a
slice of what will be offered in the
full game in addition your progress in
the beta will not carry forward the
multiplayer component allows players to
take the role of heroes and villains
from the series including Nathan Drake
Sully Elena and Flynn the game's
verticality and movement it has become
known for will also be present in
multiplayer
uncharted 4 launches in March 2016
exclusively for PlayStation 4 we may
learn more about it soon
possibly during the game Awards on
Thursday or Playstation experience this
coming weekend
for more on Uncharted you're already in
the right place